i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report and it's time for another friday
panel extravaganza
today we're going to be talking all
about critical race theory
social justice and our crumbling
institutions and i'm joined by
christopher
ruffo who is the director of the center
on wealth and poverty
at the discovery institute ali beth
stuckey who's the host of relatable on
blaze tv
and james lindsey author math phd
and founder of new discourses guys
gals welcome to the reuben report
ready to do it man this is this is the
topic
this this is this is the topic all right
so james i will start with you because
you jumped in there first
uh when when people hear the phrase
critical race theory although for the
people that know the four of us
i think they have a pretty decent sense
of what it is but if someone's tuning in
for the first time
and they keep hearing critical race
theory crt
all of these buzzwords can you give me
the 60 second recap
of what this thing is i can try 60.
we'll see
i'll give you 90 seconds go it is not
diversity training start there it is not
racial sensitivity training
you might say it's racial
hypersensitivity training if you want to
like
play little games with words but what it
is is it is a world view that assumes
from the outset
that the ordinary operating system of
society is racism
systemic racism is what they call it so
they say in their own words
that the first assumption of critical
race theory is that racism is the
ordinary state of affairs in society
the question is not did racism take
place but how did racism manifest in
that situation the people who are
equipped to figure out how racism took
place in that situation are called
critical race theorists
so it starts there it then draws into
question things like traditional civil
rights this is in their own words again
the liberal order
enlightenment rationalism equality
theory
and neutral principles of constitutional
law that's on the first paragraph
of the book critical race theory and
introduction which is a standard
textbook in the subject
so it is a completely radical way
derived from what's called critical
theory to
view race and racism to where you assume
that race
uh race is the key thing that you have
to be thinking about all the time racism
is the ordinary state of affairs racism
always perpetuates itself so if you
benefit from racism you are therefore
motivated it says
not to understand racism not to be able
to to
uh question your complicity and racism
and therefore want to maintain racism so
it's a very corrupt
way to think about race and racism and
to make race and racism relevant to
every single possible topic so that's
why i say
not to be playing word games that it is
like racial hypersensitivity training it
teaches people to look for racism
in literally every situation interaction
phenomenon
and an institution well james i didn't
have a timer going there but i think
that was that was pretty solid
that that was pretty good the reason
actually that i thought having you three
on would be particularly interesting for
this is because i think james you're
sort of hitting it
from the intellectual side i think chris
you're sort of hitting it from the
educational side and ally you're hitting
it
from sort of a religious or foundational
belief side so i thought it would make
for an interesting three chris what can
you add to that on sort of
how this set of ideas
assuming you agree with what james
basically laid out there how the set of
ideas has sort of infected
all of our education systems pretty much
at every level
yeah i actually think it's actually one
step beyond that you know in the 1960s
uh rudy douche talked about the long
march to the institutions the idea that
the way to overthrow capitalism
overthrow the united states overthrow
the kind of global white supremacist uh
hegemony was to take control of key
institutions and
critical race theory i think has
essentially done that you had people who
are more
progressive in education and
universities for a long time
critical race theory by morphing itself
into kind of racial sensitivity training
which as james suggested is a really
kind of a cover story
they've been able to actually put these
in put this operating ideology into
institutions where you think it wouldn't
go like corporations through hr
departments like federal agencies and
you know i did a story an
investigative story of even the national
nuclear laboratory so people who design
america's
nuclear weapons have been put through
critical race theory trainings where
white male executives were forced
into a retreat center for three days
they are asked to denounce their
identity
told that by being white males they were
analogous to the kkk
to white supremacy to lynching to maga
hats
and then forced to write letters of
apology so this is
not just an obscure academic theory it
was in the 1990s but now
it kind of has blossomed throughout all
of our institutions and and
i would argue has become the default
operating ideology
of america's dominant institutions yeah
so it starts
with the intellectual side moves into
all of the institutions especially the
governmental institutions right now
and then ali can you talk about how it's
affected some of the religious
institutions and what if any tools they
have to fight back
yes so this has been interesting to
watch particularly
in conservative evangelicalism which i
am associated with typically this is um
it's a world view that's affiliated with
uh liberation theology which is a
marxist type of theology that has been
around for a long time
and it was popularized in the mid 20th
century by a man named james cohn who
was
um an avowed marxist who believed in
socialism and basically believed that
jesus came not to save sinners from
their sin and give them eternal life
which is kind of the orthodox christian
belief uh
but rather to liberate oppressed people
or perceive depressed people
uh from you know the hegemonic power
structures that kind of
we have been talking about um and so
intersectionality has been a part of
some sections of christianity for a long
time but now we see it coming into
conservative evangelicalism
not so much saying explicitly hey yes
i'm a marxist and hey yes jesus came to
liberate people from white supremacy
maybe not explicitly going that far but
saying things like
well white people need to repent of
different things than black people do
and hey uh we need to divest
of our whiteness or we need to
deconstruct our faith
or we need to decolonize our
understanding of the bible
and it's basically all of the same thing
as both chris and james
have been saying but it's a little bit
christianized the problem is
going back to something that james said
in the beginning is that
this is a world view critical race
theory is a world view
it's not just a philosophy that you can
wed with other philosophies so
it's not like this is a part of my
christian faith and this is just one
compartment of it
no it changes how you view the entire
world
how from a christian perspective you
view human nature sin salvation
sanctification eternal life it's got a
different view of the end times our
purpose here on earth
um and so they can't coincide and what
we're seeing right now is the
evangelical church
trying to make them coincide and that's
why
um you're seeing so many fissures even
within conservative evangelicalism over
this
yeah and by the way it's not just
conservative evangelicalism i mean we've
seen many versions of this
in the jewish community and in many
different religions actually why don't
we just do that since
james you got into a little hot water
for for talking about this why this is
so dangerous
uh for jews this this whole set of ideas
yeah i touched the third rail a little
bit well the truth is that
um critical race theory is pretty
anti-semitic in and of itself
it first of all just as a as a
history has taught us that everywhere
you see identity politics being
forwarded we're now going to care about
people's identity and their race and
we're going to
attach that to privilege that this tends
not to work out well for jews
and critical race theory does that
explicitly but critical race theory
also has other dimensions that are are
pretty explicitly anti-semitic they're
very interested in
who is white and how they became white
so they have a whole kind of long
theory their entire books dedicated to
this uh like how
jews became white people or something
like this is the title of a book by
brodkin
um 98 or something this was written an
entire book
explaining how ashkenazi jews
became white the european descended jews
became white and then they separate from
jews of color
so you're already separating jews
according to racial characteristics and
then what the the argument is is that
the european descended jews
gained privilege that they then hide
behind the holocaust to deny
so you have this kind of group of people
who are super privileged
they be they made themselves white they
threw uh black people in particular
under the bus
to achieve whiteness they engage in
anti-black racism the argument goes
to achieve whiteness they took over all
of the i mean listen to what this is
this is
actually brockton's argument they took
over all the cultural institutions at
the highest level media law et cetera
and establish themselves at the highest
level of privilege to where they became
these
the trend setters for white society for
what it means to be white into
to what whiteness means and then they
deny that they have this privilege
by saying oh but the holocaust happened
oh but diaspora oh but you know
the roman conquest all of these terrible
things so they are they are
critical race theory builds out jews and
this isn't even without touching
the israel-palestine issue uh which
they're
also super anti-zionist but um
it bills out jews as or i should say
european descended jews
as being extremely white people who
refuse to acknowledge their whiteness
and extremely white means extremely
privileged and again when you start
calling jews privileged you're not that
many steps down the road historically
from
a catastrophe so i brought this up well
there's also there's also a great
irony here obviously that you know
everything that you just said there
was like well nazis would kind of dig a
lot of that stuff right the ultimate
racializing of everyone at every level
but but chris at the at the educational
level i still think a huge amount of
people can't figure out
how how the the schools and the
universities just had no defense
that at first you know a couple of years
ago was like oh there's this weird thing
happening at evergreen state with brett
weinstein
and we'd see like some random things
happening at a school up in canada or
something
but now it's just ransacked across
everything yale princeton heart well
harvard
for sure they've fully accepted this and
now they openly discriminate
discriminate against asian people for
the same reason that james is saying
they can discriminate against jews
because they're they're uh successful
but are you shocked that there were just
no systems in place like that these
people just like all just put their
hands up at once
yeah i mean in a certain in a certain
way yes but in another way no
i think one the thing that the critical
race theorists and their kind of
activist element has done very well is
they've
constructed their intellectual argument
almost like a mouse trap where
um they make their argument which i
think a lot of us reject i think
most kind of right thinking people
reject but they embed
a rejection of their argument as
evidence of your guilt or your racism so
you can't really say no to them or
they're going to call you racist they're
going to call you white supremacists
they're going to call you whatever
epithet of the month they happen to be
using
and this is really scary for people
frankly and especially for
people that are kind of professional
class whether attorneys or lawyers or
work in tech to be called a racist or a
white supremacist or misogynist
is a potential kind of death blow to
their status and consequently all of our
elite institutions
were really kind of poorly positioned to
resist
this woke uh kind of in infiltration if
you will
because they were essentially bullied
into
submission and silence and i think
that's what we've seen
over the last few years although i think
that in the last year this has started
to change
uh as the the consequences and the
damage of these ideological programs has
started to
have started to manifest in these
institutions parents are starting to say
hey wait a minute at what point does the
damage being done to
kids and institutions outweigh my fear
of being
kind of labeled as a racist and that
equation that equation is kind of
tipping a little bit and i think we're
starting to now see parents
who wouldn't have fought back a year two
three years ago
are now really starting to kind of gear
up for this fight
and learning how to combat this ideology
and and really get it out of our key
institutions yeah so let's pause on that
for a moment because that's where i want
to end with this because there are some
solutions that you guys are actually all
in your own way involved in so
we'll do that at the end but ali you
must be somewhat satisfied that
three what i would say are sort of
former liberal thinkers however you want
to define all these words but i would
say in many senses but guys stop me if
i'm speaking out of school
i would say are modern conservatives
because we're trying to conserve
something that was once good and liberal
have kind of come around to to your
position on this you must
take some satisfaction in that as a
conservative
to be fair well yes but to be fair
i have learned a lot from all three of
you about this particular subject
um this wasn't really something that
even in conservative circles we were
talking about a few years ago yes we've
always known that
um in particular public schools and
universities were
indoctrinating students and as a
christian we've always kind of had this
mentality because it's a biblical
mentality to have
that the world is going to have a
different philosophy and have
a different worldview than christians do
and so this idea of the mainstream
pushing kind of perverted ideas of
justice perverted ideas of love and
equality
that is it surprising to me and i
actually think christians and in
particular christian conservatives
do have a little bit of an edge in this
because it's like yeah this is just the
next
crazy thing that the world has come up
with they're always trying to come up
with new definitions of truth and right
and wrong
um and so yes there is a little bit of
that there and it's but it's interesting
to talk to people who don't have the
same faith and don't have the same
particular worldview that i have
still see the problems and still be able
to see
the logical conclusion that all of this
is going to take us to which is
resentment and bitterness and division a
lot of what we saw throughout the 20th
century and so
i mean i'm happy to be kind of strange
bedfellows with people who don't have
the same
that i do but still have the same
practical goals and
and still are able to see okay we might
you know we might all disagree on what
the problems are and some of the
solutions are but we know this critical
theory stuff
like we know that's not it so let's get
away from that
as thoughtfully as we can yeah i mean i
think not that we need more like us
versus them stuff but in a weird way
it's sort of everyone versus the woke
and it's created a lot of strange bad
fellows uh james a couple weeks ago
we we did another one of these panels on
belief and purpose and meeting and i had
your your buddy my buddy peepa goes in
on and he was talking about
how he finds it a lot easier these days
because of woke-ism
to talk to evangelical christians he's
obviously a well-known atheist he wrote
a book called
emmanuel for creating atheists so this
isn't a guy who's shy about his opinions
but he's he finds it easier to talk to
believers
and religious groups and conservative
groups
and i sense you're going through that
too i saw you just a couple weeks ago at
turning point usa a scary conservative
thing ali i saw you there too not to
blow your spot
how's that been that shift been for you
it's been really interesting it was
uncomfortable at first honestly
and it's grown more comfortable i enjoy
getting to meet people i enjoy getting
to learn what people think
and to learn from people and to learn
how they think and to see their
perspective so
that's actually been exciting it is true
that i i like peter
also find it easier to speak with people
whether they are christian conservative
and that tends to be in particular
but um if their eyes are open and they
know what time it is
then if they do not and then if they're
woke i mean they just don't want to talk
i i
wrote a controversial piece a while back
explaining why the woke
don't want to debate how it goes in a
sense against if we will their religion
to to debate or compromise to uphold
discourses and ideas that go against
their view and to to lend credence to
them by association or or by
platforming them um they can't
compromise because then they leave half
of the status quo on the table
and that's against their faith so i
found it to i find it much more
comfortable and easy
to relate to and make friends with
people whose eyes are open and they know
what time it is
and then the the the productivity
there's
of course there's always learning and
friction so you know you and i have some
disagreements ali and i would have some
disagreements chris and i would have
some disagreements
but we have a lot in common and so we
can actually you know
get comfortable with one another seeing
that we we do understand the big picture
and then we can get into that friction
stuff more positively and it's been very
enriching
so i think it's actually one of the most
um beautiful things that's happened
in my life over the past year year and a
half so i'm really grateful for that to
be honest with you
yeah well i have to say when i when i
saw you there and we got to talk and i
was like
oh i could feel it happening with you i
was like oh james is pretty quickly
going to realize like you were there so
you would already realize it to a degree
but to another degree it was like oh
guess what no one here is coming to
punch you in the face or
or do do anything like that uh chris can
you talk a little bit how
about how i sense at least that these
guys don't even believe
most of the stuff that they're peddling
so i'm sure you guys all saw
the video last couple weeks of ibrahim
kendi
who wrote how to be an anti-racist which
in essence is how to be a racist
but how he was on video talking about
how quote horrified
he and his wife were when their daughter
came home from school saying that she
wanted to be a boy
and it's like well wait a minute why why
would you be horrified by this stuff
if intersectionality makes us stronger
and
being trans is so great and the rest of
it and it's like
it's odd he didn't get canceled nobody
called him out there was no twitter
bannings but i'm pretty sure if tucker
carlson
had said that about his daughter things
might have been a little different
yeah i think the double standard is
really the point and i think
a lot of times conservatives point out
the double standard and they
kind of express outrage but this is
really the wrong
tactic i think the the point of the
double standard is that
these people hold the institutional
power so the reason that ibram kennedy
can get away with this stuff or nicole
hannah jones can get away with this
stuff
is precisely because they are protected
by the institutions
they are in a way the key holders to
this power and
if we want to actually make a difference
complaining about the double standard
isn't going to work it's actually going
to be shifting the battlefield shifting
the power dynamics
and coming to a point of parity where
the woke and the anti-woke actually have
a kind of kind of kind of equal and
opposite firepower so we can negotiate a
kind of central playing field because
right now i think you find
uh conservative organizations and
conservative
kind of influencers and writers and
thinkers are being held to one standard
but
you know in in a way you have to stop
being complicit
in the double standard that's the other
solution to it you have to basically say
hey
you know what i'm not going to play by
those rules i'm going to stand firm
i think james has done a great job with
that i mean james
is the kind of guy who takes risks he
swings hard he doesn't always land the
punches but
um but i think that he doesn't operate
on the opponent's
logic ali do you think conservatives
have dropped the ball
on on some of this stuff that they maybe
that
i would and i would include myself in
this at this point like that we all just
we all see it and we think by calling
out the hypocrisy of it that that's
enough
it's like oh that will wake up people
these people are obviously frauds
yeah i think that conservatives just by
nature and even maybe by definition are
constantly on the defense and that's one
of our defensive tactics
to try to say you know look how crazy
these double standards and this
hypocrisy is but we're very rarely on
on the offense and i think everyone on
this panel actually does a good job to
countering the arguments of critical
race theory and positing things that
are better positing ideas that are
better and
talking about why social justice and
social justice theology social justice
ideology
is um is is not just and it's not equal
and it doesn't achieve the kind
of utopia that these critical race
theorists say that it is
uh going to so i do think conservatives
are sometimes afraid to be on the
offense especially when it comes to for
example quote
racial justice issues or anything to do
with race
because we've almost internalized this
idea that
certain kinds of privilege or certain
kinds of categories
discredit us from entering into these
arenas and having these conversations
but
like chris said we've got to get off
that turf like we can't be using their
definitions
we can't be intimidated um by the
tactics that they're using to say
look this panel of all white people
isn't allowed to talk about critical
race theory
that's exactly how they shut down
conversation and
i think everyone here does a good job of
saying well i don't care
anyone with a logically thinking brain
can talk about this and combat these bad
ideas
and we should totally unapologetically
well what is it uh
do you think uh ali i'll start with you
on this one we'll go the other way
around
what do you think it is about you that
makes you brave enough to do it because
i have no doubt that you guys get the
same emails i get i don't consider
myself a brave person i'm just saying
what i think for some reason i'm not
really sure why
but like a lot of people are just
crippled by the fear
they don't want to deal with the twitter
mentions that james is getting a
thousand times a day
you know and and even if these are not
real people and their bots and trolls
and everything else like what do you
think it is about you
personally that allows you to do this
well i can't take a whole lot of
personal credit for it i think i'm
motivated by the fact that i've seen
this ruin people's lives
i've seen this tear apart people's
churches i've seen this put a strain on
people's marriages i've seen it tear
apart
families um this idea of categorizing
people according to their perceived
privilege
and this idea of lived experience being
elevated to absolute truth
it has absolutely destroyed people's
faith in people's theology
and as a christian it is someone who
believes that the calling to truth is
an eternal and primary one i mean
i i feel a lot like martin luther did
when he said you know
peace if possible but truth at all costs
and i see this kind of deception that
sounds so good to christians who want to
be loving who want to be merciful
who want justice not realizing that they
have redefined all of those things away
from what the bible says they are
to what um secularists and what leftists
and what progressives who want nothing
to do with the christian faith
say that they are in in so doing they
have
completely shipwrecked their belief
system
and ruined relationships and i just it
breaks my heart it makes me sad and so i
don't know if it's so much courage
as it is this sense of desperation that
i don't want the minds of children
corrupted i don't want families torn
apart by this
i don't want people's faith to be
shipwrecked by lies
and so i guess i just feel a
responsibility to kind of steward the
platform
that i have to tell the people who do
listen to me hey this is wrong and
here's why and not only that but from my
perspective
you know the bible the gospel gives us
something better there is a truth out
there
it's not this it's this that's what i
feel my responsibility is
yeah well from the gospel then to trump
chris in in
your world from where you come from it
was not easy to say you were supporting
trump because he was fighting critical
race theory in the institutions
and and everything else how how tough
was that for you
yeah i mean it was tough you know i cut
my teeth getting involved in local
seattle politics which is absolutely
brutal
and i remember that initial period of
getting harassed getting doxxed having
people
float posters of my face around my house
having people
yell at my kids at the playground i mean
it really like
visceral kind of rage and brutality and
hatred from
these people who in their professional
time preach compassion and tolerance
and that beginning period was very scary
uh you know the first time some of those
epithets got thrown my way it felt like
an attack on my identity an attack on my
reputation
and i remember those moments but then
you get over that threshold and you
realize that there's nothing
on the other side to stop you and i
think once you break through that
initial period where they
they really try to bully and silence and
intimidate you
but if you can actually just make it
past that
and actually exert kind of strength and
fortitude there's nothing
else to stop you and actually at that
point courage begets courage courage is
kind of a snowball effect and people
recognize it people support you people
come out uh to appreciate what you're
doing and
i've just found that once you break
through you can achieve a kind of
personal uh kind of psychological inner
freedom
uh to really embrace what you believe
and then it's also
battle tested your ideas that you've
been maybe privately believing once you
kind of expose them to public life um
your ideas only get stronger and your
convictions only deepen
ah i love that man i mean that that's it
that really is it right there so james
you know last time i had you on my show
it was i think i had you on with pete
and you guys were
were on together and i said to you when
the cameras went off i said
you know you're gonna have to ally with
the conservatives on this stuff this is
like two years ago
and i sensed you were a little you know
maybe not yet but then you did
you did support trump um so
did you see that as sort of like an
inevitable conclusion with all of this
not conclusion but
well just i guess the next step um i saw
it as a necessary one
i i don't know that it was was
inevitable but when
it got to the point where the the media
is holding trump accountable for things
that are just made up
if you want to call that accountability
and they're not holding biden
accountable i started to get nervous
when they start talking about packing
the court i get more nervous they start
talking about
equity plans i get more nervous i'm like
oh this is going to be he has no
resistance he can smoke
so it was it became inevitable because
of the behaviors
of the two gentlemen over the summer but
something did shift and i don't know
what it was
before the weight of that hit i think i
told you this when we were in florida
was i had this moment where
i used to be horrified by everything
trump said and we're just kind of i
can't believe he says that and then all
of a sudden i realized it was funny
you know all summer long i couldn't stop
laughing
and i would watch him and i would laugh
and i was like something has shifted
and i don't know what it is but
something has shifted um and so
once i started laughing at him i think
it became inevitable that
uh but i'd already made my alliances at
that point right i had already reached
into
the southern baptist convention i'd
already reached into conservative
christianity i'd already reached
into different conservative strongholds
if you will and started to build bridges
make friends listen hear
learn and so it wasn't a hard step
in that regard to take the i guess if
you want to call you know
okay i'll vote for trump with some
reservations a
uh you know final step into to
you know off of the cliff or whatever
apparently it was people are still
freaking out about it i get canceled
more over having said i would vote for
trump and then i get told i've never
explained it i've explained it in a
podcast i explained it on tv in three
countries i mean i don't know what in
the world people want from me
but um it's like they can't hear the
explanation it's so bizarre
but i'm glad you didn't ask me to to
follow
both of the two before me and even
yourself where you said what the courage
comes from or you just said you just say
what you think and you don't really know
why it happens
uh and i chris's articulation that
courage builds courage was so good
and then ali i just really want to like
hit the fact you brought up martin
luther it's funny that you know
atheists or whatever that i have to say
that i also think of martin luther an
awful lot and i always think
here i stand for i can do no other um
and also given my twitter behavior i
suppose i also think of his i guess
famous
hopefully not apocryphal line that when
i pass wind rome trembles
that's everyone's twitter i think yeah
so
so actually i think this would be a
perfect one uh to go out on here is that
you guys know that one of the things i'm
saying all the time is like we can't
just talk about this
we have to do something and i do sense
that the three of you are doing
something i think
the thing that i'm doing beyond just
this part
is that i started locals because i felt
that woke-ism was going to destroy big
tech and i
you know so so that's my foray into
actually doing something
but you guys are all doing something uh
different in your own community so chris
i'll start with you
what are you doing on the legal side who
are we suing
yeah right everybody everywhere uh but
no we're we're
you know when when the election kind of
happened and biden won
i didn't follow the kind of rabbit hole
on critical election theory
uh and what i realized is that the
executive order that trump passed
banning critical race theory-based
programs from the federal government
was going to get overturned by the biden
administration immediately that actually
turned out to be
quite true the first day in office one
of the 15 things that he did was
get rid of the uh the executive order uh
passed by trump signed by trump um right
away and so i spent the intervening
months really reaching out to
the conservative legal movement to other
institutions to say hey
who is suing government and corporations
and schools
that are doing these absolutely
outrageous critical race theory based
programs
and the answer was well nobody nobody
nobody
okay well you know i have now a database
of you know more than a thousand
whistleblowers across the country
who would take up this legal cost and
the answer was
essentially we have not really fought
this fight the right
the kind of think tank right has been
really fighting on economic issues
uh since the reagan era and they're not
really set up or kind of
organized to fight these cultural
battles so
rather than kind of give throw in the
towel and give up i
i took some leadership and i reached out
to
even smaller law firms and reached out
to people who wanted to volunteer and
i assembled a coalition it's called stop
critical race theory fairly simple
we filed three lawsuits now against
institutions that are doing these
programs
we're going to be filing one again in
the coming weeks and we're going to be
filing
even more after that in this year and
the goal is
really this is to show not only is
critical race theory a bankrupt ideology
but actually these programs that are
based on critical race theory
that traffic and racial stereotypes that
reduce people to a racial essence
that harass people based on their
protected categories of race and gender
are actually illegal under the civil
rights act of 1964
and unconstitutional so the goal is to
rack up some lawsuits
change the calculus for institutions put
them at legal risk for doing these
programs
and eventually over the next few years
because it takes time
to get at one of our cases in front of
the supreme court of the united states
to win and to permanently essentially
abolish these programs
from american life yeah i have to say
that even as bananas
as la is we had you know one of these
uh special things that you could vote on
in our in the last election that
basically was going to reverse the civil
rights act
that was going to actually put racial
markers to be the deciding factor on
whether you get hired by the government
here in la and believe it or not the
people of la rejected it i was
beyond shocked james what are you
actually doing because i know you're
actually doing stuff
well there's a few things one is in fact
the twitter behavior
um so sultan becomes a huge
inspiration in times like these and so
one of his
his statements that i take to heart and
i want other people to take to heart
is that he said may the lie come into
the world
may it triumph even but not through me
so speaking the truth and just being
willing to continue to speak the truth
and not participate in the lie
and to commit yourself to that is very
valuable so i've
done that i hope obviously i also am
still working as hard as i can
to i'm philosophical in some orientation
i'm a bit of a dork
i'm trying to lay out as much track
as possible so people can understand
what this is
and run the trains like the ones that
that chris is trying to run
that will get the lawsuits going that
will get legal uh entities equipped to
be able to fight those legal battles
i'm also trying to reach out to i have
limited reach but i've had some success
so far reach out to conservative
republican governors and state
legislatures to try to copy that
rescinded executive order
at the state level not only would that
have been necessary
or is that necessary with biden having
rescinded it i think you know exactly on
that first day
it would have been necessary anyway i
received hundreds if not
thousands of emails asking me you know i
work for the state of oregon i work for
the state of wyoming
am i protected by this federal
executive order the answer is no you
work for the state and so the states
need to be copying this anyway so i've
i've reached out i've talked to
some of the officials in texas i have
some roads in on florida the the two
sanest states it seems i guess south
dakota is very sane right now too
but we've got to get these republican
governors to take this issue seriously
and to copy that order
clean it up a little bit probably and
copy that order to start protecting
people to state level and also
to give frankly in a sense that middle
finger to
to the biden administration for doing it
i'm also trying to encourage journalists
to understand how hard they can push
back
biden rescinding that order means that
biden's
administration wants to do one of the 11
things that that order prohibits
it turns out having diversity training
is not one of them c section 10
teaching it in college is not one of
them c section 10.
c section 2 though it's racial
discrimination racial scapegoating
racial stereotyping
calling the country fundamentally racist
and evil which one of those things
because it must be at least one of them
does biden and his administration want
to do why is he not being held to
account
for this deliberate neo-racism that he's
he's institutionalizing you talk about
systemic racism he's putting it in
on purpose deliberately yeah i mean
that's the fascinating thing
the people who are screaming about
systemic racism all day are the ones
that are actually now
putting it into the system because if
racism existed in the system i have no
doubt
that all four of us would be screaming
about it ali what are you doing
well to be honest it is a whole lot of
talking in a lot of writing but
what i think it is accomplishing at
least from the correspondence that i
have on a daily basis is that people in
particular women
my audiences large majority women a lot
of them are young moms they've got kids
in school
or they're going to a church or they're
a part of a bible study or maybe they're
in their college class
and they're hearing um the importance of
reading things like white fragility or
how to be an anti-racist i had a lot of
friends post the black square
after um after george floyd happened
over the summer
and i've just seen a lot of confusion
among christian
women who are my age who just want to
know hang on
what is actually true because i'm
confused this sounds good this sounds
right but there's something about it
that doesn't seem
quite true and so my goal is not just to
tell you okay this stuff is wrong here's
what the bible says which
i do obviously from my perspective think
that's really important but
here's what you say like here's what you
can say to your school administrator
here's what you can say to your
professor
here's how you engage with your friend
who disagrees with you
on this here's what you say to your
pastor here are some resources for you
and thankfully the messages that i get
are i feel equipped for the first time
to actually have conversations about
things that a few weeks ago
i didn't even know i didn't even know
they existed or people who say
i'm going through diversity and
inclusivity training or whatever it is
um at work and i actually you know
held a meeting with my boss and i talked
about where i think
that it's going wrong and why i think it
doesn't actually you know this
descriptor of pervasively racist doesn't
actually describe our workplace
and i was able to you know stop it or
curtail it or whatever it was and so
there are real stories thankfully that i
receive and i'm sure all of you have
received from people
saying i changed the curriculum in my
kid's school my pastor is no longer
recommending white fragility to our
church
our professor has amended her syllabus
um
whatever it is my encouragement is to
say
whatever spear you occupy you absolutely
have
influence because as chris said courage
begets courage
the it is very likely that there are
other parents there are other students
there are other congregants there are
other community members
who feel the same way you do but they
don't want to be the racist
uh or the so-called bigot who speaks up
and so it is up to you
you don't have to be an influencer to
have influence you don't have to have a
twitter account you just have to have a
voice
and you just have to be a little
equipped you have to have a little
knowledge and a little bit of courage
just a little bit of each of those
things
to stand up in this fears that you
occupy and say
something and um i think at least on a
local level it's amazing how quickly
that house of cards can crumble
um and so change is possible i don't
know if i'm completely optimistic that
it will change
um on a large scale i hope so but i
think people can make a change
um in the in the world and in the circle
that they live in ali bringing us home
like a champ
ally james chris i thank you guys and
we're going to link to all your stuff
down below
have a nice weekend and i'm i'm going to
close up with the youtubers you guys can
you guys can go do important work now
you know
all right see you guys thank you all
right guys look
look i think we gave you a little
something there to think about
you know i know this stuff it feels huge
it feels confusing
it's like who wants to read every single
book to understand every single
reference and all of that stuff and and
truly
i don't either i don't either because
people need to live but i think
james particularly although all three of
them did james particularly hit
something
at the beginning about the
all-encompassing world view that
woke-ism
seems to have taken on that it is sort
of overriding everyone's belief in
everything else
and if you don't believe in it it will
come for you so
let's do what ally said there at the end
whatever that is
in your local community and what chris
said about
bravery begets bravery it's like all
right
if you can stand up a little bit because
i know that none of the four of us think
we're that special in that regard but if
you can stand up a little bit
maybe you can get someone else near you
to stand up a little bit and maybe they
can get somebody to stand up a little
bit and then maybe we can fix these
things
all right that's a little something to
ponder for the weekend
have a good one everybody i will not be
on the twitter but i might be posting
steak pictures over at
rubinreport.locals.com
have a good one and i'll see you on
monday
you